[Applause]  I'd like to mention that in Jeff Schloss  picture he spent the morning after with  Jane Fonda and then got paid for it say  you're both nominees tonight how's it  feel well I know that if I lose I can  always go back in space for another  three thousand years  oh please don't because first we've got  a very special task here before us away  yes nominated don't do that yet  nominated for Best Performance by an  actor in a supporting role are Tom  Berenger in tune  and his sisters  any man  willing to falling to do  [Applause]  [Applause]  and the winner is Michael Cain and  Hannah and her sisters  [Applause]  I know how much it would mean to him to  be here and having worked with him I  know how much he deserved it thank you  you